Alex has just completed his graduation
from Stanford University
one fine day he receives a mail from
Star Trek Technologies for an interview
for the designation of a software
engineer as referred by the University
Alex was really happy and excited about
this and starts preparing for his
interview next week while he was
preparing Alex came across the term
downtime
Alex has no idea what is a downtime
he decided to seek help from his uncle
John the software engineer
John explained that downtime is a
specific time frame allocated to deploy
or update changes for a software product
in a real-time environment and this
happens because most of the softwares we
use today are developed using the
waterfall model
for example
Cisco one of the popular leaders in it
and networking globally is using agile
methodology for their subscription
billing platform SBP as it was
originally developed using the waterfall
model
after adopting the agile methodology
Cisco's product improved its overall
efficiency where defects were reduced by
40 percent compared to the previous
releases and effect removal efficiency
increased by 14 percent
upon explaining what downtime is John
further added that downtime is a small
part of the waterfall